there's something my sister would want  you to have  [Music]  [Music]  it was the last night of her training  laya told me that she had since the  death of her son at the end of her Jedi  past she surrendered her saber to me and  said that one day it would be picked up  again by someone who would finish her  journey  a thousand generations live in you now  but this is your fight  or we've done all this time  I want you to know that you have been a  real friend or to my best one in fact  [Music]  of course  [Applause]  for us together  [Music]  a wilderness Roddick started  [Music]  not the house and generations live in  you now  this is your destiny  [Music]  [Applause]  the force will be with you always  [Applause]  you  you